ce samedi le paris 14 s'est
exceptionnellement arrêté en gare
d'argenton-sur-creuse contraint et forcé
par les habitants de la ville qui n'en
peuvent plus de voir seulement passer
les trains on est très nombreux
aujourd'hui
et puis l'été licence avec nous donc ça
c'est une grande victoire
et puis on va pas s'arrêter là surtout
on va y arriver à la victoire une
victoire dans un match qui se joue à
trois
d'un côté les usagers du train de
l'autre la sncf et les pouvoirs publics
pour les premiers la situation ne cesse
de se dégrader depuis plusieurs années
le développement du tgv à concentrer les
efforts et l'investissement au détriment
des autres lignes chartreux paris par
exemple la deuxième ligne ter la plus
fréquentée de france avec près de 20
mille voyageurs par jour
galère toujours pratiquement ya pas une
semaine où il n'y a pas quelque chose
soit un train supprimé soit un train en
retard
soit des incidents pendant le parcours
on n'est jamais informé on n'arrête pas
de le dire ça va en se dégradant on en
vient même à regretter quand ils ne font
pas grève parce que ça marche mieux
quand ils font grève au moins en un plan
de circulation qui a respecté tandis que
là quand il ya pas greg on est toujours
un petit peu dans l'expectative on sait
pas toujours si ça va bien roulé ou pas
pour tous ceux qui font le trajet
quotidiennement des retards incessants
qui ont parfois des conséquences
redoutables
moi je suis très déçu et pas fiable et
j'envisage une mutation parce que je
suis fonctionnaire et franchement alors
je suis très bien dans mon travail est
un principal motif de la notation ça
sera la gueule c'est de la prise
d'otages de l'usagé c'est pas du service
saas et plus de service public c'est la
honte
excusez moi je vais y aller chartres
paris une grosse épine dans le pied de
la sncf qui assure avoir pris la mesure
des difficultés
selon la directrice de la ligne on a mis
en place énormément d'action et on a
déjà des résultats depuis plusieurs mois
avec la par exemple depuis quelques
semaines une ponctualité une qualité qui
à 95 % ce qui est un très bon chiffre
pour nos 95% de ponctualité en moyenne
sur l'ensemble de la journée
mais selon nos informations ce taux
serait loin d'être atteints sur les
horaires de pointe
en dix ans le trajet chartres paris
s'est allongée de près de 15 minutes
un sérieux handicap pour le maire de la
capitale beauceronne chartres peut avoir
une vie complètement différente si on
met des directs sharks paris 1
très tôt le matin 1 après le passage
fort du matin jeudi par exemple 6h30
ensuite 9 heures et le soir retour 17
heures ou 20 heures et on pourrait
inventer des journées très longues
6h30 20 heures des journées très courte
9h 17h et là on modifie complètement la
relation de chartres avec paris
comme toutes les lignes à problèmes
chartres paris à son association de
défense des usagers
ce matin-là ses représentants au rendez
vous à paris avec le président de la
région centre val de loire qui finance
la circulation des ter à hauteur de 196
millions d'euros par an sur la base
d'une convention signée avec la sncf
si on a moins ça va un petit peu ce qui
va se passer sur paris chartres au
niveau des remboursements de mois jobs
puisque la région est devenue en
quelques années un acteur incontournable
du transport ferroviaire
on attend de la région qu'elle fasse
vraiment km vendant en place des
pénalités financières parce que jean lui
déclare jean on peut tout simplement
dire j'ai qu'avec l'argent donc il ya
des vrais pénalités financières pour que
les ccef prenne ses responsabilités il
ya des pénalités dans la nouvelle
convention il ya des pénalités qui sont
d'un niveau sensiblement
ils ont plus que doublé par rapport au
passé ça veut dire que si la sncf ne
répond pas niveau de risque de
régularité suffisant elle sera prise au
porte monnaie
les finances le nerf de la guerre le
rapport spinetta remis en février
dernier au gouvernement préconise de
fermer certaines petites lignes mal
entretenues comme tours loches par
exemple une gare déserte d'où partent
deux trains le matin et au arrive de
train le soir les usagers mettent plus
d'une heure pour faire les 47 kilomètres
qui les séparent de tours est de plus en
plus les cars remplacent les trains
annulés
on est complètement pénalisé parce qu'en
plus on n'est pas au courant souvent
donc on arrive à la gare personnes
nommées au courant donc on attend et
plus bas soit on fait du covoiturage
sont obligés d'attendre une demi heure
trois quarts d'heure pour prendre le car
suivant donc on arrive barbe retard je
ne suis pas satisfait qu'il y est très
peu de trains entre l'os et tours
voilà pourquoi bas parce que je viens de
paris je rentre de paris
tous les samedis il y en a très peu le
vendredi aussi situé en semaine pareil
pour remonter
la sncf est capable de dépenser des
centaines de millions d'euros par
exemple à la gare de montpellier une
gare de montpellier sud qui ne sert
strictement à rien il ya six trains par
jour qui s'y arrête
on a dépensé des sommes considérables et
là elle n'est pas capable d'investir
pour 40 millions puisqu'il n'y a pas de
si longtemps au contrat de plan état
région on était à 40 millions pour la
rénover correctement donc la sncf
des fois on ne sait pas à quel jeu joue
en france ils ont une petite idée quand
même quels jeux vous pensez qu'elle abat
la fermeture c'est clair et net
en attendant la région a déjà déboursé
près de 700000 euros pour rénover un
pont à la sortie de la gare de loches
afin de pérenniser la ligne comment on
peut accepter que ce qui existe depuis
plus de 100 ans qui a véritablement créé
un aménagement équilibré du territoire
des relations entre les villes
préfectures et les ville sous-préfecture
irriguer les territoires ruraux comment
on peut imaginer ou 21e siècle au moment
où il ya les problèmes de gaz à effet de
serre etc
on va arrêter ces lignes je refuse
d'envisager la fermeture de tout bluff
des pouvoirs publics qui investissent
l'argent des contribuables pour
conserver des lignes que la sncf
n'estime plus rentables la situation est
pour le moins paradoxal pour le maire de
loches 6000 habitants l'enjeu est de
taille
foncièrement il ya une colère après il
faut trouver des solutions foncièrement
ya une colère parce que ça fait des
décennies en fait qu'on a abandonné la
politique d'aménagement du territoire
la métropolisation c'est bien mais c'est
pas suffisant nous on est en train de
crever si on continue dans ce sens là
donc les territoires dits périphériques
ils nourrissent une population
l'alimentent largement surtout des 800
comme nous on alimente 50000 habitants
il y a les gares ou les trains ne
circulent plus est celle où il ne
s'arrête plus argenton sur creuse dans
le sud de l'indre a perdu de son attrait
autrefois bien desservis sur l'axé
toulouse paris la petite ville qui
compte aujourd'hui moins de 5000
habitants est de moins en moins
attractive seulement deux trains le
matin vers paris et au départ de la
capitale
plus aucun après 17h40 alors que plus de
20 trains passent tous les jours dans la
gare sans s'arrêter
une situation qui bloque le
développement d'activités comme celle du
cne ac le centre national d'enseignement
agricole qui délivre plus de 1000
diplôme parents s'impose pour un moins
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
horaire ça certes c'est sûr et certain
que commencer son cours à 9 heures et à
11 heures on l'interrompt parce qu'on
n'a pas de train c'est une contrainte
totale vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis des
enseignants des avis des élèves ils
n'ont pas demandé malheureusement
d'arrêter leurs cours à 11 heures avant
qu'on avait le choix d'avoir plusieurs
horaires de départ ça permet très
pédagogiquement construire un programme
qui était pas qu était cadré qui
correspond aux responsables ce que le
ministère demandait argenton sur creuse
toute la population est mobilisée à
l'accueil de la mairie
une pétition à temps les administrés
quand j'étais étudiante justement je
prenais le train pour aller à
châteauroux
et ça évitait mes parents faire le
trajet justement donc je trouve ça bien
pratique plus de 9800 personnes ont déjà
signé un chiffre qui n'étonne pas le
maire de la commune
je pense que petit à petit il y à ce
qu'on appelle un glissement de la démo
grâce de la démocratie représentative
vers la démocratie participative c'est
et les décideurs de plus en plus sont
attentifs à ce que pense la population
est pas ce que renvoie les élus le
comité de défense de la gare
d'argenton-sur-creuse qui compte plus de
300 adhérents a écrit à la ministre des
transports et rencontrer les dirigeants
de la sncf
en vain alors ce samedi les usagers en
colère ou décidé de passer à l'action
bonjour connaissez j'ai un petit rappel
pour la manifestation de cet après midi
pour la défense de la gare chez vous
dire une chose je te le chef de gare
d'argenton ya 15 ans
et quand je vois dans l'état qui est la
gare au niveau voyageurs fret
ça me fend le coeur de voir tout ça je
suis une argentonnaise de coeur ma maman
habite encore là ça m'arrive de venir et
pour l'instant je peux encore venir en
voiture mais le jour où ce qui aurait pu
venir en voiture mais j'aimerais bien
pouvoir venir en train qui en est un qui
s'arrête en gare d'argenton on y va à la
tête du mouvement
il y à martin hirsch inscrit une
comédienne qui effectue souvent des
allers-retours à paris pour son travail
c'est devenu pour moi un combat beaucoup
plus pas seulement un combat personnel
c'est que j'ai vraiment pris à mon
compte
le combat de qui c'est un petit vivent
là qui sont complètement délaissé le
plus dans tout juste acquis aussi flynn
est ce que tous les services publics de
proximité
les dessertes ferroviaires a tous à y en
a marre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le cortège rassemble des gens de tous
âges milieux sociaux et tendances
politiques ainsi que les maires des
villages alentours c'est vraiment toute
une population tout un territoire qui se
mobilisent et derrière on espère qu'on
va être entendu et que des rires et que
la sncf et ministère des transports on
reverra sa copie et en prioritairement
sur l'enjeu du trad du soir le train de
retour du para et de paris en fin
d'après-midi ou en soirée
constat des trams qui ne s'arrête plus
tout un symbole pour une population qui
se sont oubliés et traille rapide de
notre desserte ferroviaire l'état vente
la mobilité pour tous et l'attrait de
nos magnifiques campagne il souhaite que
les pénos il développe et que fait-il
pour tout cela il supprime les services
de santé de transport d'éducation sans
offrir d'alternative efficiente tuent
les emplois qui y sont associés et
compromet ce qui pourrait se créer et
dynamiser notre région
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les manifestants ont pénétré dans la
gare et ont envahi les voies provoquant
l'immobilisation du train chaos paris
qui d'ordinaire ne s'arrête jamais
argenton sur creuse
préserver une garce et préserver la vie
de leurs du canton de comme la maternité
du blanc c'est ça fait partie des choses
évidentes parce que si on nous ferme
tout ça on aura pris fin 2019 le marché
des ter sera ouvert à la concurrence
peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour des
lignes comme paris chartres où le prix
du billet pourrait baisser à l'image de
ce qui s'est passé en italie mais le
train est il encore une solution
d'avenir
lorsque l'on sait que le contribuable
finance 60% du prix du billet les choix
politiques et économiques dont les
habitants d'argenton-sur-creuse ne
veulent plus faire les frais